stoicism these are some of the key ideas
some of the key values for that more
fear rationality we're going to talk a
lot about that in just a minute
freedom which is going to be tied
together with rationality duties
fulfilling duties and then choices and
stoicism is it is a moral theory that
appeals to a lot of people who are
motivated these sorts of values
especially do fight stoicism probably
most discussed by military where people
in sort of a military kind of situations
where you have some sort of opposition
and where you you also you know read
instead where it's going what does that
fall to my injury somebody that's a
stoic okay very good person who doesn't
care we also use it as sports to know
doesn't show emotion yeah that fits in
well maybe we think that they don't care
because they
here okay they stake out a stand and
that's that's where they are
those are those are all the aspects of
what we entered popular culture call
call stoic and the stoic personality
tends to be somebody who is both
creative and free free of their emotions
free of what other people think of them
we were able to commit themselves to
something and saying well you know if
you don't like it and we have a lot of
movie show action heroes all that
actually makes sense
all men ties in with this is more theory
we'll see why it was there's a natural
emotion was not care to liest of it in
what sense is to like it really doesn't
care and sees it as a good thing
the first thing we'll talk about this so
rationality this is something that's
distinctive as soon as we've talked
about this before with Plato we talked
about this a little bit before we talk
about hedonism you know there's certain
pleasure that human beings could enjoy
that other animals don't
what's distinctively a different kind of
creature a higher kind of
I'd say a dog or even the chimpanzee
we're pretty close to us physically in
the two-percent different the genetics
the DNA of us is 98% chip DNA but that
other 2% makes a big difference in
careful rationality Epictetus talks
about something that calls the ruling
part
he also speaks in terms of reason right
or the rational or the use the word
template of faculty and the emphasis
here is all on the ability to see itself
and seal the place another aspect of
this that's equally importantly what he
calls moral purpose with the also has
the choice in for the stoic not only are
we different from the other animals that
we can do something that they can't we
can actually backup from ourselves and
look at ourselves a dog doesn't ask
itself am ia good talk if you learn
that's a good dog from humans recordings
it's a bad routines it learns what what
counts as that and sometimes there could
be struggles but a dog doesn't actually
question it so I would say it's my life
on the right track
I mean in cartoons right but in cartoons
elsewhere pants you know have jobs that
they're modeled after human beings we
answer for more flies we don't know
whether it whether chimpanzees are
silent teaches them sign language snot
down lets us project that onto them we
don't know whether they have
conversations they don't have what is it
how did I achieve my good they don't ask
themselves is my wife on a good track so
far do I need to make some changes
you know they certainly know you don't
have midlife crises or you know have a
birthday sometimes people new years life
together we do you guys by this point in
your life I'm willing to bet that you
have gone through at least several
different crisis moments where you had
to decide what kind of person you wanted
to be not just then but for the future
and where you may have decided to change
the course of where you were going you
were able to do that in part because you
were able to step back and actually look
at yourself and he used the very faculty
that you were scrutinizing to do that
reason rationality or the ruling
because you mean it can look at itself
your sense of vision can't look at
itself when you could look in the mirror
you're putting in your content but
that's not quite the same thing as
actually judging its top and the same
thing goes with your versions and in
short does your I mean your body is
great things easy think about energy
reticular the enemy class or have any
different under those museum displays
where they have the bodies have been
preserved in some sort of plastic thing
and they pull all like the veins of
capillaries I mean it's just how complex
that is for the nerves
your body's amazing they put together
machine but honey doesn't have the
capacity to reflect on itself your mind
those part of your mind
right Bob this is your body this is
great massive stuff your emotions your
desires your aversion to your emotions
reflect on themselves when you're sad
does your sadness tell it's okay that's
enough I don't know you got to back that
on your mind again you can actually tell
yourself I guess this isn't healthy
third day I've just slept in all day
nothing
yeah if you said that something like
that to yourself happened
you were actually using that ruling part
of yourself reason to tell yourself hey
and together this thing that's going on
here it's not good when you felt joy you
know did your joy ever say to itself
this is really nice right now
but I kind of watch it something might
happen to this and then I'm not going to
feel so hot it doesn't work that way the
motions doesn't there's the cognitive
part of you and that there's the
effective part the feels that desires
that yearns that avoids that fears all
these these sorts of things it actually
makes you do things and this part can
look at itself this perk and this
purchase does what it does and this is
the other aspect though you have a
faceted choose and your choices are free
Docs choices aren't really fruit this my
trouble in fact would be rewarded for
punishing animals for choices that in
large part results in making even little
children you know aren't entirely free I
think I mean I told you guys about this
thing if I had my little son dead he's
just about to turn five yeah
so when he was solidly and available
before year-old fair there was something
that he did and I don't remember what it
was and I said if you do that again
you're gonna get punished
he's probably he was messin with his
sister in some way
they're probably driving and what extent
is really straight now if I were to say
to you if you do that again
you're gonna get punished you understand
this right are you gonna do it again you
did stop you'd say no right
I'm not going to do it you would choose
he said and this is so so evocative of
that that stage of life you said I hope
I don't do it not oh that I won't do it
he realized okay if I do this punishment
happens don't like punishment
therefore I shouldn't do this but he
also sort of instinctively realized I'm
a little kid I don't actually have
control over this stuff entirely I'm not
altogether there constants and what do
we know about this that's actually the
case of your capacity for self control
or cell formation all those sorts of
things it's not really fully developed
at least the parts your greens and
handle em until you were in your toys
some say you know 25 some do in the
garbage and you're getting more and more
adept at this aren't you finding that as
you're going on it's not just that
you're getting better and better than
your your body is actually doing it
still through some changes
either these are plans to do this well
you have a free will you can improve not
only what you do you can choose who your
big be what kind of person you're meant
to be again oh I can't do that the dog
doesn't want to get punished it can
change its behavior to avoid punishment
that's what happens from training the
dog to do certain things it's better
actually to get the dog if you would
advise to do - we associate the board's
what is the dog freely choosing them not
really
this is why stepping back and saying
this I need to make these kind of
choices in order to make that happen
I needed to surround myself with
positive role models positive trends
we're going to help me out by the way -
good doggies no right again that could
happen in the cartoon I suppose now
we've got some live action movie but you
do that don't you
you've probably done stuff like heaven
how many of you got rid of friends who
you realize we're negative most of you
that was a choice that you made freely
because you actually reasons something
else
but if you actually thought about in
terms of I'm not as good of a person
with this this friend of mine it brings
out their lamb tendencies I gotta quit
hanging out with them because every time
that I hang out with them I end up
acting like a jerk I don't want to be a
jerk you used this back with your choice
and use that not just to do one thing
use that to try to change who you are
the structure of your motivation
structure so that's pretty important
isn't and if you want to boil stoicism
down into a nutshell it's going to be
the good it is to be found here it's not
to be found here and it's certainly not
to be found and things external to your
body outside of yourself the good is to
be found in developing who you are
developing your rationality developing
the freedom doing that your duties doing
that through choices all the things are
going together so one of the things that
that
Epictetus asks this is a portion of the
discourses that I had you read for this
he's talking about rationality and it
says
this isn't chapter 2 first book of it to
the rational animal that's you only the
real rational is intolerable
only that which doesn't make sense only
that much it doesn't actually that was
just ran channel is powerful you can
understand why something has to be the
case you can you can put up but if you
can't understand why it's the case but
it doesn't make sense for you it doesn't
fit in with these things then you're
going to be very upset by it says moles
are not naturally intolerable getting
yeah how is that
well speed on the sparkles that's the
last time acid ammonia ins and they're
whipping when they've learned that
whipping is consistent with reason what
are the sort of things that people put
up with that treatment when they realize
that it's for their own benefit what's
up yeah yeah gym class you know when
there's gym class or a fire thing now
I mean it's first off there's a lot of
fat kids out there gym class and then
you know if gym class was there was a
time for a lot of kids so you want some
steam that's why deprive them of that
well then the other thing is gym classes
also if it was done right informational
character one of the things that you had
to do in gym class it was a play I mean
you might go to every there were some
kids are like super athletes and they
were great and everything so I'm putting
putting those kids on and then there
were some kids who no matter what
happens nothing was gonna go away right
let's put them up for the bulk of the
kids you know you might go into gym
class and you're like playing football
and you're good with that part of it but
you don't really like it you're not very
good at playing volleyball but you got
to do it anyway because the gym teacher
says you have to well you know if you do
that eventually you start to become a
little bit better at those motor skills
that are needed for that and you also
learn a very important life lesson the
world doesn't revolve around you
any word desires or aversions right gym
teachers are great for saying suck it up
and so I think it's kind of a bad thing
to deprive kids with that sometimes
unpleasant experience that I know I did
all of you have gym class yeah so is it
just kids now we don't have that's just
really too bad well what do you need
like in high school basically got it in
elementary we had yeah the college
every other what you shouldn't have to
college you're an adult you can choose
one that's the way some places they
don't well that would substitute so now
thinking about a little bit more what
are the one of the things you can put
out with physical place let's see if
you're not just in gym class what do you
put up that you don't like Lisa yeah why
don't we don't you like it stinks I'm
not good at so these are things you're
not good at physics what is it about
running let's say running for a couple
miles it's challenging what's it like
physically well you can't breathe in
sometimes your lungs actually go now do
that walking enough what happens you get
used to it you get better at it pretty
soon a mile doesn't seem like anything
to you you start to acquire a capacity
greater capacity of the lungs your heart
you know cardiovascular activity hurt
get stronger pretty soon you can do all
sorts of things for 30 minutes straight
that you didn't think you could possibly
do it for even five minutes train and
that's a good thing right so if you
realize that that's what you're aiming
for the first stuff that you don't
really like it makes sense it's rational
if somebody just you know throws you
and they say all right now on we're
doing an hour of calisthenics every
morning they do this awful look possible
good is this I wanted an exercise I
would do that on my own you know then it
doesn't make sense to you now if
somebody explains to well we're doing
this because it's important to us that
we stay alive for a long time energy you
might still say you know you're kind of
treating me as a feminist and a hundred
at school I don't really like that if
they said something to you like well you
know this is for your good we want you
to live a long time because we're
concerned about your health
yeah sometimes sentence too if you're
willing to do this sort of thing where
you said incentives yeah those tend to
work better than just hurting everybody
inside you're gonna do this now that's a
lease for American in some some
countries that's just what the company
is doing so let's go on as he says the
rational and the irrational appear such
in a different way to different persons
just as the good and the bad the
profitable than the untrodden some
people have you know the right ideas
about these some people have wrong
headed notions you know there's some
people that are really really touchy
about everything that's because they see
everything is you're rational they see
it as you know unendurable is something
that
you have to put up with as may be
directed that that is not making sense
when people see that something is rash
good they're much more willing to put up
with it even if it's not longer they
they don't enjoy it and he's got this
great example here he says for this
reason we need discipline or to learn
how to adapt the preconception of the
rational irrational our preconceptions
can be good or bad they can be well put
together or you know all over the map
and disorganized to several things
conformably nature in order to determine
the rational irrational we use not only
the external thing so we get into
situations right we experience things
whether it's rational or irrational to
us depends partly on that stuff but we
consider also what is appropriate to
each person so what may work or may be
rational for one person may not be
rational for another and this is where
you know their duties may come or also
in this example these guys were just
kind of a crude example it's also kind
of funny example it's what you value
he says for one man it's consistent with
reason to hold a chamber pot for another
to look to this only he doesn't hold
that he will receive strikes he's gonna
be beat and he will not receive his food
but if he holds the pot people that
suffer anything harder disagreeable but
to another man not only does the holding
of the chamber pot appear intolerable
for himself but intolerable also for him
to allow 100 to do this vodkas
what's a chamber pot everyone know how
to interpret it
it's like a toilet except it doesn't
flush right in before we have flush
toilets it before came up with latrines
and stuff like that you would do your
business in a chamber pot in your
chamber in your in your room and then
you go dump it out summer and
most people don't like dealing with that
sort of thing just like most people
don't like changing diapers you know why
do we change that because they're not
gonna change themselves babies don't
change their own dangerous right but you
would think that most people could take
care of their own chamber pot business
right but people don't generally like to
so if you can get somebody else to do it
and you know who did this in ancient
times why is he talking about not
getting food and stripes do termite
mainly servants or slaves and you'd say
well yeah it's unfortunate but you're in
the one down position so you're going to
handle this this you know unpleasant
business for me and if you don't do it
then I'm gonna publish it now it makes
sense if food or not getting beat
there's really the be-all and end-all it
makes perfect sense like that decree
says hold the change you know if getting
you know three square meals a day if
that's the be all and end up you'll do
pretty much anything right for some
people they say that's not for me that's
below my dignity I could also change or
for somebody matter of fact I'm not
going to insist that anybody else hold
it for me that's a different kind of
approach and they're both different ways
of seeing of using this to think about
what's what's rational so he says
if you ask me whether you should hold a
chamber pot huh
he says you got to figure that out you
have to he says I say to you that the
receiving of food is worth more than the
not receive you know being scourge is a
greater indignity that not being
squished if you measure your interest by
these things if that's your choice about
how you arrange your desires that is a
choice if that's where you are
then it makes perfect sense to hold the
chamber pot it makes perfect sense to be
somebody's valet in China
boots make all their appointments do any
of these sort of things that other
people might find demeaning yeah it
wasn't that kind of like they're doing
then do this but you don't get to do it
you get the yeah now notice yes doesn't
that make us the person themselves
chooses to you know we could think of
all sorts of other things you know
people often phrase these would you
let's say you were married somebody says
I'll give you a million dollars I can
sleep with your spouse just one you'd
have to think about it right
million dollars is an awful lot of money
now they only said I'll give you a
hundred bucks but instead your spouse
odds are you protonated you're crazy
right I mean if you actually say
your spouse and they say sounds good to
me
you're probably some sort of problem but
a million bucks now it's now some people
would actually think about it
the question is which do you value more
your spouse and the relationship that
you have with them what a million
dollars which do you value that's that's
a matter of your choices and yeah I I
can't tell you I can tell you what you
ought to choose but I can't tell you
what you actually do choose you have to
actually look at that yourself so it
says if you measure your interest by
these things go and hold the chamber
five and he says but this would not be
worthy of me well then it's you must
introduce this consideration into the
inquiry now I for you know yourself how
much you are worth to yourself and at
what price you sell those you will sell
yourself for men sell themselves at
various prices you know what what goods
would you sort of sell yourself or give
yourself over to somebody else or you
know if you think about the chamber
where do people still do this hospitals
right we call it a benefit somebody's
got to do it that might be a different
situation it might be you know sort of
being somebody's servant like let's say
they wouldn't either somebody would pay
you say nice
I really all you have to do is be a
chamber it's all you get a rest of the
rest of days here you got to be on a
call nature's gonna take its course
well you know that would be an
attractive prospect for you that you
value that five thousand bucks a month
more than you value the indignity of it
but why might you actually empty
something needs chamber powder bed pans
in hospital because they can't take care
of themselves at you longer why don't
you change somebody's diapers because
you love them and you need to take care
of them because they can't change it
themselves it's a different value
Elizabeth it's a different good yeah it
could be rational to change some of
these diapers but not rational to the
answer though you know they're probably
plenty on Craigslist or something
Frank solicitors expert for the
chamberpot valet you see the difference
there right and this is a very silly
example but you could even transpose
this into just about anything that's
epictetus is point you have to think
about your own structure motivation you
have to think about what matters what
you would order highest what you would
lower and the Stoics think that you want
to order some things high this and other
things you really shouldn't care that
much about so this goes to the beginning
of the Caribbean he talks about what is
actually in our power what do we
actually have control
it's probably pretty good this let me
add one do you care about what people
take anybody let's call that reputation
these things are valuable to you
now let's look at the way at stoically
and let's look at it through this legs
what's in our power what's in what's not
what's in our control what's not in our
control so he says some things are in
our control others not things in our
control our opinion pursuits
desire aversion and in a word whatever
our own actions whatever it is our own
concern it doesn't sound that much like
these things does it but desires or
versions those have to do with these
things
these are all desired things I think you
want money
that means you desire you want to watch
baseball or play baseball that means
that you you desire them our versions
would be the things that aren't done
this was probably or if there are some
things on this list you really don't
like like some people probably tiny but
in this classmen some people keep having
freedom everywhere them because they're
kind of afraid of freedom
that would be an aversion right what our
universe to gain imagine Oh
because otherwise you're probably gonna
screw up your body if you're not averse
to pain pain tells you quit doing that
what else are University maybe the loss
of some of these things somebody takes
your freedom away makes it impossible
for you to experience pleasure
reputation you would be a person of that
right you also you have control over
what you think that's what opinion is
how do you do things and he says the
things that are in our control are by
nature free unrestrained unhindered
those in our controls are not in our
control are weak slavish restrained
belonging to others other people have
control over some of the goods that we
do in fact as item that part of the
message of stones that's one of the
starting points the Andy says remember
that if you suppose the things that are
slavish by nature are also free now look
once others is your own you're going to
be hindered you will lament you will be
disturbed you will find fault with both
gods and men but if you suppose that
willing to be your own which actually is
your own and you leave others you have
theirs you're going to have a happy life
as it says you will never do anything
against your will
no one will hurt you so what I actually
are the things that you don't have
control
well let's use one example right here
you do want people to think of you in a
certain way right you do regard that as
a good other moral theorist so we're
going to look at like say Harris Tom
they think that's a good - is it really
genuinely a good for somebody like
epictetus well you better control over
your education you do to some extent
right you can you can choose to screw it
up
but even if you do the right thing you
guys all probably experienced this you
can do the right thing
does that dictate how other people are
going to see you what they're gonna say
about you how good things go wrong how
are they going wrong in your experience
use yourself like doing something that
wasn't your actual intention yeah one of
the most common experiences of life and
shared life the other is being
cross-purposes doing something that's
that you think it's good the other
person thinks you're you know kind of
control over that or you're only after
money or something like that how does it
go when you try to explain yourself
or sometimes yeah they're you again you
don't have control over even whether you
can fix those the other person has if
somebody wants to be an obsolete apps
they can be obstinate ass and there's
really very little you can do about that
you can try to punish them and all the
rage but how productive is that I think
that you all probably try this right now
right somebody's trying to doing that
with you what's your natural reaction
somebody started saying you shouldn't
see things this way you should see it
this way because that'll make me look
better how do you react
do you generally comply you might
actually like you know give sort of lip
service and say yeah yeah I understand
your point of view or sure or whatever
you know I think you're a great person
because if you work in that's really
what they want the reputation exists in
other people's eyes if what that person
wants is their reputation to be able to
certain sort they're kind of setting
themselves up or to support the right
thing as a matter of fact a lot of these
these things are out of your control you
you have some degree of control like you
can't lay the groundwork for a
successful job but well here's a sort of
sand example right now the job market is
pretty bad right it's unfortunate for
you guys because you're close to getting
out of college
great so you might think why'd you go to
graduate school
instead another a couple more years and
I'll get a masters and maybe a PhD and
then I'll get a job for sure right
well that really I mean in my field in
philosophy for every job that I applied
for it there's 300 applicants not
average although they don't they write
you back these letters would say I'm
sorry we didn't you know we didn't hire
you
there were 323 applicants with search
and you know you can you can use any
tool I I guess I shouldn't feel there's
so many how could I possibly have gotten
ice getting sevens every time but you
know you still feel a bit down about
that right it wasn't well because the
world doesn't revolve around here right
you're just one bit of it and so if you
will you get a PhD in a field which is
highly competitive
there's already a lot of other people in
the field that aren't retiring and
there's not a lot of jobs opening up and
they're actually in some places closing
philosophy departments and you're gonna
be you're gonna be successful at your
job there we actually laying yourself in
for not probably just a potentiality but
a probability of being disappointed
being upset and I know a lot of friends
who go from job to job job was teaching
in a one-year year or two years here
we're teaching like I am right now as an
adjunct when you I hope all of you do
those did you do everything you can I
know embarrassed this is very good about
a placement and internships and all that
so that'll help balance it out a bit but
it is you don't have a lot of
controllers lesser friends and family
family right off the bat you don't
actually have that much control over you
all read the expression you can pick
your friends but you can't pick your
family don't say that to your family
because anyway you know feel bad
slurring and stuff think you actually
don't pick your family at least like the
family that you grew up with yeah they
may pick you you might like I am for
example the adoptive but I don't have
any stake in that I mean there could be
some situations where like you're a
foster kids and I want to be with these
people that please go find some more
placement well then they just assign you
another foster care I need some guys
four members with five or six foster
families your friends so if your
happiness depends on having these sort
of things you may be laying yourself in
for unhappiness what about health do you
have control over that
again it's something green don't
exercise you're definitely not to be
healthy
but can you do all those sort of things
it's like let's not be healthy
yeah unfortunately there's there's
people who you know run every day and
they eat you know low-fat low-sodium
diet they died of a heart attack at 40
and then you look at me say wow that guy
could have been indulging himself all
this time he missed out because a lot of
these these things are not actually all
that reliable they're not within our
power
I think Yunus thinks that this is though
freedom I think you can also say that
knowledge at least you know if my
knowledge would be means something like
the way you want to live your life is
within our power it might not be within
your power if you mean something like
access to the library over there that we
have at Marist you know we take that
sort of stuff for granted
I have a friend actor actually a
colleague who is involved in a project
to deliver a whole bunch of USB drives
and a little thumb drives to Africa and
the reason why he's doing that is
because nowadays if you want to work you
could just put a whole bunch of them on
a USB Drive right there's not an awful
lot of books and a lot of Africa but
there are strangely enough more and more
computers or you know terminals of some
sort that you could actually a little
bunch of PDF files on to it and access
it there we take that sort of stuff for
granted but there's a lot of places
where knowledge is pretty hard to come
by
so what are other things that you don't
have control well a lot of the things
that were averse to so you know
reputation is something we want that's
something we desire what's something we
reversed to pain poverty happiness says
ultimately you can't control whether say
the market ruins you or not I know
people who you know we're set to retire
five years ago and suddenly they lost
three-quarters of the value of their
their retirement now they're still
working disease maybe again if you wash
your hands
you're probably less likely to get
diseases right if you take care of
yourself you're probably less lucky but
could you still die of some sort of
terrible disease could you catch
something that you don't really have any
control over I mean why do people not
like to go to hospitals
yeah what is one of the sort of things
people actually get I mean sometimes
somebody will come into the hospital
with some minor thing and then they die
what happened they get a flesh-eating
bacteria
you know versa you get some disease
antibiotic resistance strain of the
disease and generally the sick people
are there in the hospital you get a
staph infection a lot of people get
pneumonia in hospitals you don't have
much control over that I suppose they
don't give a lot of money you could like
you know request a good hospital and you
know keep everybody else on your wing
but that depends on you having a lot of
money you have an awful lot of control
over that how much so stoicism is in
large part saying you don't have control
over a lot of things we do what did you
actually have control over like he said
what do you think or opinion you also
talked in other places about don't walk
alone or things like that these are all
ways of talking about what it is that
you believe what it is that you think
about things your attitude that you take
towards that you have control
interestingly enough over what you
desire and what you're averse to let me
say it one more time because that's kind
of a revolutionary thing to say in our
society and it wasn't in Greek society -
you have control over what you desire
not just over what you do or what you
actually desire when you think are good
things and what you think are bad that's
what you are reversed to you to shoes to
see something one way or the other
not just mentally not just cognitively
but effectively or emotionally
so somebody insulting you
is that a good thing or event make you
feel good or make you feel bad yeah
don't fly you're averse to it right it's
something you don't like to see it as as
a as an evil users point of view of
somebody insulting you them is really
neither a bad thing or a good thing what
makes it a bad thing for you you choose
to see it you are invested in seeing
that so what's some other things and you
are seeing as good or bad things make
you see things yeah you don't he's not
he says that it's neither a good thing
or a bad thing it's not saying it's a
good thing he's not saying she'd go I'll
try to get insulted he's saying we think
of being consulted as a bad thing it's
really either good nor bad
what we do have control over his house
and he actually says when somebody
wrongs another person like you know they
behave in an insulting manner where is
the the harm it's not actually in what
the
person is doing it's in one's attitude
towards them so if you can change that
attitude towards that so that you don't
see it as a bad face you see this just
just a thing you know just what it is
then you're actually going to be acting
aren't you because you're not going to
be negatively affected by it I can be
hurt by why are you hurt by people
that's all of you because you care about
it if you're a stoic ideally you want to
get to the point where you you don't
care about that that sort of thing and
there's you know there's different ways
of not caring so people say oh I don't
care and you can tell that really deep
down inside they do they just sort of
push it all down they don't worry yeah
that's not what stoicism is advocating
it's advocating actually changing the
way in which you think about things and
by doing that the way that you feel
about it in in that it's very similar to
a type of psychotherapy called cognitive
behavior there or sometimes it's called
rational that actually had it started
this century in people who had studied
stoicism and one of the insights because
that we have control over our emotions
we have control over how we see things
not just you know they're not just
imposed on us they're not just there and
then we have to react to them we
actually have some choices we have some
responsibility and that gives us some
freedom because you're say an angry
person why do why do people get angry in
the first place why do you gotten angry
saying last week
who's gotten angry now one way or
another in the last week I'm not looking
for this specific example of you know
well first he said this and then I said
that and then this person said that what
sort of things get you yeah okay one of
the ones that intention okay somebody
else is in your space or they feel
you're in their space in our argument
about whose space it is it's common
space and through all these sort of
things in that escalate that's what's
going on there
why does it get you upset her
okay yeah I can understand that in many
situations like that
so you have a desire that can't be met
and whose interfere with your desire
down on their person right and then same
things happening with you and they're
maybe they're telling you I go somewhere
else I'm gonna maybe that hurts your
feelings right well if you were hanging
around the house all the time
now their feelings are hurt - right
where does all this come from it's
because of what we desire and what we
reversed it you know like other people
telling us what to do that's something
we reverse - because we see that as a
bad thing we want to be validated by
other people tell us you know you're in
my space we feel like we're not being
valued right when other people are
impinging on our space we feel like they
don't value us we see these as good or
bad things we have a choice
yeah that's that's the ultimate cause of
feeling angry that we feel but the other
Christmas not just hurt us they've
wronged us they've done something that
they shouldn't have done they didn't
ever write to you well why do we have
that sort of viewpoint again because we
haven't managed to disentangle ourselves
from all these things out in the world
or even having to do their own body our
own feelings that we don't have a lot of
control over what what do we actually
have control over how we see things what
we choose to Center our life grow
Epictetus talks about I'm actually the
tide both is more in the next class
session so I'm used somewhat different
materials dishes together he talks about
the human being as being different from
the animals in one key leg and it's not
going to be associated cities or you
know play music for things like that
it's that we have a part of us that's
rational
what he calls the ruling part the
animals don't have reason or at least
they don't have
you know you debate about to do dolphins
or monthly fees or not get some chips
apes have reason and the verdict is
still kind of out certainly they don't
have it the way that we they're not
taking ethics classes right as far as we
know signed up down the middle we'll see
we do that reason we have as part of
ourselves that can reflect on the world
can reflect on other people can reflect
on our body and our desires to reflect
on itself and it can actually take a
stand
not just in seeing these things but it
can judge them it can judge whether it's
doing a good job or a poor job other
things can't so you know epictetus for
example talks about the art of carpentry
can tell you a lot about carpentry can
tell you when you want to use carpentry
no can tell you about anything other
than carpentry great not to tell you
whether the carpenter is a good person
or a bad person
what about your your designers and your
emotions anger can tell you something
hey that person's a juror I should do
something to hurt that in response
that's what it tells me right can anger
actually step back and look at itself
and say wow this is really over the top
maybe I shouldn't do this we can we
talked about this a little bit with
Plato right the most or the spirited
part of your soul you can't actually be
act up and look
it's off and say maybe I shouldn't be so
angry practice it's a matter of fact
what is the anger tell you then you all
all been here what does anger actually
tell you when you start having thoughts
of penny I'm going to father this what
does that drive tell you all in the grip
of anger right no no no this is this is
exactly what you should be doing as a
matter of fact you should be doing more
you really deserve it
say another bad thing they sent two bad
things to you say five to that that show
that sort of reasonings going to have in
your head you made choices based on that
Oh much better person than I they using
a lot as an example these classes of
partners I haven't actually myself you
know over the last 40 years have
struggled with it a lot made some
progress but not not as much as I want
you to me
as far as patinas and stoicism over this
concern the only thing you could really
rely on is this itself the value of
having your moral purpose and of course
nature later on in the discourses he
says what is the nature good he says
what is the nature of the good flash
certainly not an estate and land by no
means fame
no is it intelligence knowledge right
reason yes here in that simply seek the
nature the good for I suppose you don't
seek a bit of planners no you seek it in
a rational animal no if you then seek it
in a rational well why do you seek it
anywhere except we the superiority of
rational over here rational creature we
are we different this is we're putting
the stoicism our good truly lies and
he actually talks it in some sort of I
don't want to buy breaking this up put
you in mind of sort of religious people
that we think about today the Stoics
have a certain kind of religion is very
handy it says your superior being
you're a portion separated from the
deity you have in yourself a certain
portion of it why then are you ignorant
of your own noble descent will you not
remember when you're eating who you are
who you are who eat and who new feed
when here it's little intercourse when
you're exercising yourself when you're
engaged in discussion know you not that
you are nourishing it exercising that
God you're carrying a God rumbling
around something extremely valuable with
you and what are you doing you're
probably selling you know if you're like
me I'm not very stoic you're probably
selling this down for other things
you got a skewed way of evaluating
Thanks so if that's the case then we
don't want to think about how we would
change them and we'll do that in just a
minute before we do that I want I want
to think about a few examples one that
I'll tell you about from my own work
when I first started teaching I was kind
of a hot
I got angry at students quite a lot but
it was dissatisfied with the performance
classroom and let it upset me actually
my first job was you know my first
full-time teaching I was teaching in a
maximum-security prison and so you've
got you know murderers and rapists and
kidnappers and they're there in my
classes and one of the things that they
actually got a kick out is what I would
like blow up and down like a student and
they wouldn't sit back and some like
that the charge on they can see my ears
turning red first but they knew after a
while or Spencer the second no asking
certain questions do you have to read
this why would something like that sent
me a lot well because of certain
assumptions it wasn't just a matter of
my emotions
unless you have corresponding watts or
assumptions and these have to do with
the nature of what's good and what's bad
I mean I expected that every student
should be just as interested and stuff
but I'm teaching yes I am his reading
and studying and talking about it
although is that a realistic assumption
no any of you disagree
I mean you think it's a realistic
assumption some yeah well they're
probably you know they have a hard time
and that's certainly that I heard find
myself there's a lot of other
assumptions built into it as well but I
think that was a part of it is that this
is really I will stop this is great
things you should want this you should
you know see this as a good creature
stuff you should behave like people who
see it that way
now try to cut corners or you know I
didn't read everything that was assigned
to me either
what I felt you know something that I
forget that when I'm a professor and
you know there were a lot of different
thoughts assumptions a lot of different
emotions yeah what would have all this
means is they lead to actions I would
actually blow up that students do you
think that made things better you know I
find yellow that some student is that
going to make them want to do the right
thing and recognize the value of you
know because it's something I was
teaching was behind ball is that going
to help the student realize the value of
it and say you know that's what jerks
like now I know I hope lot of study that
stuff so I don't want to be a jerk like
you
so needs to cover productive actions and
you have enhance habits that not only of
actions but also ways of thinking about
things so the next time I go into that
classroom how am I thinking about those
students these dummies probably didn't
do the vision that's an assumption so
the huge amount of judgment right is
acting to help things coming in with
with a assumption like that that's going
to actually screw things up more and
that's going to be a reflection of my
emotional state and all these things are
going to feed into it and what's the one
thing that you notice isn't in there
that's really important if you want to
start take control of us breathe well
that's actually gonna come in here and
that's gonna bring up an interest of
course on let me defer that for just a
second what else
choice
I had a choice in how I looked at these
things I had a choice in whether I
allowed my desires or a genuine good bit
of learning to this community this way
is to make me angry students I didn't
race about what I did with my anger I
had a choice in my actions and I also
have a choice or not quick so directly
about didn't
Epictetus does something really
interesting there's a little bit later
in the discourses I want to read this
this passage to you because what he has
to do with let's do with habits this is
this chapter xviii deep to the
discourses it says never you have it in
faculty so even the reason itself every
habitat faculty is making it increased
by the corresponding actions they
haven't walking by walking and running
by run should be a good reader read if a
writer right but when you have not read
30 days in succession that have done
something else yield all the consequence
you guys you've all experienced that you
go on break good reading stuff now we
can come back to this a little bit
harder ISM he says in the same way if
you've laid down ten days get up an
attempt to make a long walk to see how
your legs are weakened so if you would
make anything a habit do it if you would
not make it a habit
don't do it but accustom yourself to do
something else it's the same way he says
with the affections of the soul when
you've been angry you must know that not
only is this evil to follow you being
angry is not pleasant is it I mean some
people actually get addicted to it then
I guess it could be present but is it
Pleasant overall and let me know a lot
of types of consequences
yes I finally a lot of the works that we
mistake I relate to one another back and
forth like McIntyre and his idea in
regards to your narrative and the
choices that you make and if you
continue to make a bad choice you're
going to lead down that fat and as
you're talking about having this is kind
of like almost the same thing yeah it's
something that look people that we're
going to see this semester to talk about
habits as well and choices so he says
when you're angry you must know that not
only has this evil to follow me given
the Bolton's
you've also increased to happen that a
man throw fuel on the fire so every time
that you allow yourself to become angry
respond in anger keep thinking those
angry thoughts that reinforce the anger
you're strengthening the habit of
getting angry in these sort of
situations if you want to break the
habit
you actually have to make a choice one
which doesn't change things all you're
trying to take the hammer can you change
a heaven just to say oh I'm not going to
be any person anymore
I'm not going to be a fearful person I'm
not going to be you can't think about
just I don't like this person although I
don't have any good reasons not to not
to like them because they're a nice
person I just don't like them
if you decide to change your mindset
towards them doesn't happen immediately
what he have to do
see that yeah keep doing it everyday
somebody else progressed start liking
yourself because the fact that you don't
like something is your and yourself is
why you're probably hating you might
have this person it's the assumption of
yeah you might have to do some
introspection with and with progress you
want to actually figure am i making
progress or going to look at yourself at
least a lot and you get it you're going
to keep the other you have to make a
choice to keep making that kind of
choice but you can do them because
that's what our Faculty of choice allows
us to do if you don't choose to do that
if you choose you know it's a life
saying and I'll try it this one time and
they say had it didn't work for me they
say I think I just have to dislike this
person was your choice right you chose
to say I'm not really the changes I'm
just gonna Dylan Thomas we know when it
comes to reason that so I wanted to come
back to this epic epictetus thinks that
our Faculty of reason is not infallible
it's screwed up and part of what we have
to do is actually use our choices to
slowly strip away wrongheaded
assumptions that be probably you know
finally a good stoic I would realize
that I probably should be exercising
I want to live to 80 and if I want that
to happen they certainly can't you know
stay at this weight and not exercise why
am i doing it well the part I don't like
exercise it's not my desire I have an
aversion to it and I and I want to do
all the things that's done I'd rather
read books
those are habits those are the actions
well some of the guests that do with my
mindset if I would actually get straight
in my mind about the real values of
things would make an awful lot easier
for me to feel the right way do the
right thing and that would change those
habits would so her Faculty of reason
has to be developed has to be purified
it's not an automatically revival God so
he says he says this with other things
too
he talked about this with with sexual
desire you have got overcome in sexual
intercourse with a person didn't you
sleep with somebody that you didn't
intend to sleep with when you went out
but by the end of the night you know you
decide you've hooked up and then the
next morning to say oh this is stupid
they do that he says don't recognize a
single defeat reckon you've also
nurtured increase your incontinence or
your lack of moderation your lack of
control over your desires he says in
this matter certainly as philosophers
say diseases of the mind rub once you
desired money if reason be applied to
lead to
evil desire stopped the moving faculty
of our minds restore to original
authority so that's very fancy language
we're saying you don't think about how
you can value if you start to the value
money is because you normally do you can
actually stop yourself and say wait a
minute
money is good but this stuff is better
but if you don't do that what's gonna
happen you're gonna start to say yeah
money's really I really need to have
money it needs to be higher than these
other things well he says he says
something of the kind he happens with
diseases of the soul certain traces and
blisters are left in it and once a man
shall complete completely a face then
when he has latched on the same place as
the national cruise now Lister's with
sores if then you wish not to be of an
angry temper don't feed the heather
throw nothing on it which will increase
it i first keep quiet so that's that's
behavior right does that change how you
feel not but you have a choice when
you're angry you have to insult somebody
or do something else
don't feed that yeah don't think angry
thoughts
I mean you've all been angry and you
know what it's like when you're angry
you're arguing with somebody and then
like you say I can't talk with you
coming down on meetings they don't
respect me you're saying all these
things to yourself right you know this
and that
Wow I start to see a larger pattern
there they do this and this and this and
this they don't like me at all they're
not really my friend and he's drinking
now I really will those emotions
thinking about you they create habits so
if you draw a line from actions right
you're acting on emotions that would be
a lot easier to make the right choice
instead of thinking of creating habits
you just make that one right choice
yeah instead of thinking of not greedy
and bad habit yeah take it out we're not
feeding ya think about doing the right
thing
sure yeah add some more stuff to the
picture and then you know Epictetus does
you know the consequence that he thinks
about mainly is this is screwing you up
yet
good business - you're right
that would be a very useful way you
wanted to change your habits or choices
thinking about the likely consequences
or hora consequences the eventually
experience I want to do this
see this gives you a lot of examples
like when you go to the bathhouse
you know don't don't get upset with some
of these flashes here because that's
what happens such as mussels I'm going
to go to the houses
that's committee and that was a big
thing back in in Greco Roman times
nowadays we associated with sort of
homosexuality and things like that
it wasn't the bathhouses beverage places
where people fight and they socialized
yeah got massages and took the asset
like hot baths from cold baths and you
know you go but it was like and then
you've ever go into the public pool they
have a public pool here to catch the I
don't know what's a link in the public
pool as opposed to somebody somebody's
home pool what's up yeah it's noisy
right and you got to watch where you put
your stuff cuz somebody might steal your
stuff that's why it's good to go in with
a bunch of people and then like you know
this group will stake out this spot in
the pool is their spot and these are all
the inconveniences they put up with
right so you another relate to that or
when you go to the movie theater how
many ghosts okay first off what's your
biggest
yeah yeah I mean it's astronomical how
much you have to pay to go to the movies
when I was a kid there was a place that
we could go from a buck and granted they
were older you know their movies that
like hitman shelter and like kind of
months or so but we could go for a [ __ ]
you know and then they start jacking up
and I took my kids to the movie theater
to see the Chipmunks movie recently we
must have dumped like 100 bucks between
popcorn and candy and sodas and then the
tickets themselves now they actually
bistro the movie theater or Starbucks
coffee there too
okay so the price what else what else
ruins your theater-going experience
sometimes yeah
someone's going on yeah yeah yeah
people who talk some they could give
advice to the movie yeah we were awful
kids when I was a kid we used to like to
sit in the back we buy things that we
did throw we were something at health
for people you catch them try to watch
some movie that's a kid in the back it's
throwing like you okay so if you go to
the movie theater these are all the sort
of things that are gonna happen so what
are you gonna do with a hand
I mean you have a choice if you were a
stoic you could say I came here they
have a really good time and not to be
bothered by anybody does that gonna be
productive what what is what does your
reaction gonna be like that you're gonna
be mad we're gonna beat the cra-- sir
what if you tell yourself I came here
with the intention of keeping my Faculty
of choice for moral purpose in
accordance with nature that's my primary
good night this sounds very artificial
right then you would do this in a
certainty they would make this part of
your habit if you tell yourself I didn't
actually
if that happens that's great but I came
here trying to do the same thing as I do
everywhere else in life trying to keep
my cool trying to keep it together
trying to make some progress in life
then when somebody throws somebody in
the back some jerk it throws a malted
milk ball gets you in the back of the
head how are you gonna react a little
bit differently right you might you
might say that's really you know this is
the sort of thing that happens it's
unfortunate that it happened to me but
it's really just sort of luck of the
draw if I was sitting over this way you
would have been somebody else who got
any of that yeah really got nothing to
do with me personally it's not like the
world is out to get me it's not like
this kid is out to ruin my theater-going
experience this is just something that
yeah and this is part of the price of
the movie another example like you to
think about is
what are you looking for you got to eat
what makes it a good experience what
else yeah
services good aspect and that could be
conversation that's probably enough to
go on so let's let's think about this a
little bit more so the food is good what
what goes in
nothing worse than salad we're like the
lab such you have acabas ground
my aunt Elena tells the story over and
over again when they were kids they
never melted because it was and they
drive up to Canada from Chicago to go
solitons and they would stop at a
restaurant that was a big tree somewhere
other than mom's kitchen and grandpa
would make them word all the same dish
because the theory was the cook will
only be cooking one can addition it'll
come out quicker
is he a driver of course you know if you
know anything about the restaurant
there's no logic there at all actually
the cook might actually irritated it has
to make the same thing and it drove
uncle ate nuts because you know his
thought was you go over a restaurant so
you can hand what you want to eat you
don't have to eat the thing that that
person next to you is meaning and that
was taken
we don't think about this that much but
if you start going to fancier and
fancier places there's something that
they call presentation that that's
that's what good service there's good
service
okay that's important now you go
sometimes it can make you feel like you
yeah yeah that's pretty important too
you know you wanted water to every so
often you know you know won't have to
heat come on over here it's even worse
for handling gesture another waiter
waitress or servers would come over and
take care of their table that's probably
company could be conversation some
people like to go and take a look along
that's their conversation anything else
getting any that could make a bad
experience with company could date like
jerks they're abusive to the leader okay
so with this experience of doing
anything about it the way of spelling
point is there anything wrong with going
out to you I mean if you're stoic could
you go out to eat yeah
something wrong with that it's not like
you would lose your stomach credentials
by having somebody else prepare food for
you but one of the things that can go
wrong in these ways well any one of
these elements could be missing from the
experience are you going to dump when
you have that experience are you gonna
wallow that to to get to sanitation okay
when you go into a restaurant look for
that help health inspections for if it's
below you know the high 90s you don't
want to because sanitation is very
important but you know with all these
other things you have a choice whether
you allow these things to get to you you
can handle desires for these but realize
when you have those desires if you place
your happiness and having a server who
is attentive you're probably gonna have
a bad day I was a half the servers out
we're not very attentive so number are
particularly
but ready often they're not just point
often they don't want to be there there
might be effective where heat so you get
the general idea right but the the stoic
approach to things is to focus on these
things they haven't there before freedom
freedom is as a primary good rational
life that's a primary good
plain old student right that's on our
daughter basically okay you kind of
morning through that book oftentimes
desk okay sorry even to be a boy forever
girlfriend doesn't be our a is certainly
treat these are probably a good mix now
with any of these roles yeah
yeah and now a lot of that will depend
on things like habits and your mindset
and your emotions I think there would be
certain Franken pie that would probably
make something go would be some of the
what were some of the expectations
what do you yeah that's a big one what's
one other everyone come back to that
created well [ __ ]
yeah nurturing yeah they should they
should actually like you for who you are
maybe not just for your money or back
you know you have friends that they like
or you do their homework for them they
actually do some nice things for you too
because they like you so being faithful
could there be some some habits or some
desires or some you know frames of mind
that would render a person much less
likely to fill those duties with
fidelity I think so if you're a sex
addict you're gonna have a hard time you
know put away from that's a matter of
habit that's also a matter of affection
this is an extreme case right that's a
matter of your the aspect of designers
and that's a matter of your mindset
you know to some degree that's a matter
of choice no you didn't choose whether
to place yourself in situations where
you feel tempted
we're not choose choose not to France or
something you can choose as soon as you
start getting tempted to get out of
there or not alright what about being a
son or daughter
what should a good son or daughter
medium obedient to you know reasonable
Thanks what else be helpful
be respectful know these are these are
important things now Epictetus
asks you there's appears that we're
gonna leave off with he's talking about
brothers actually he says does your
brother Roger did your brother a bad
brother to you that could be the case
right do you have control over whether
your brother's a good girl you have
control over whether your boyfriend or
girlfriend is good when you have kids
you can have control over whether
they're good sons or daughters I mean
there's ways you could definitely screw
them up to make sure they're gonna be
bad sons or daughters there's ways you
can scrub the wake of a girlfriend
go ahead and cheat up afterwards but for
the most part you don't have control
over what you do have control over is
how have you been yeah the fact that
they don't behave the way that they
Oscar really has nothing to do with you
still have control you have a choice in
whether you fulfill your duties and
whether you're a good person from
stoical point of view is may depend on
whether you do your things and whether
you into the kind of person who can rely
on do their duties even if they're
facing the kind of adversity that we all
do face so it's an interesting moral
theory you don't think about whether it
could work for you there's certain
elements that are certainly very
attractive you might not you know buy
the whole package though I know I
certainly